reside now resigning is still your folio
right now how long have you been living
there for the past 14 years where were
you born I was born in Havana Cuba what
year were you born I was born in 1952
and what point did you come to the
United States came down to the ice tree
in 1967 did you move immediately to the
Miami area I was a write in Miami in
1967 and two years later went to a stay
in New York City what were you doing in
New York
y'all went to school there what school
did you attend went to the hakonsen high
school hung William Paulson State
College where they located relocating
and held on new years help on New Year's
Eve and after you completed your
education did you then start to work yes
I did what kind of jobs have you held I
was the media manager for STP
cooperation and right after that went to
offer Danny cooperation how long did you
work with STP about two years for them
where was that
they base in Chicago I wasn't ever gonna
margin and stay afloat Ian then what did
you do there from nice TP Corporation I
went to work for Danny cooperation they
base in Gastonia North Carolina he now
wore them for five years what did you do
for them how was the view the manager
for the state of Florida at some time
did you personally go into the seafood
business yes I did when was that that
wasn't 1982 1982
yes sir what business is your father in
my father's in the real estate business
now before strike that
would you describe the nature of the
seafood business that you went into yes
how to pull the microphone just a bit
closer yes I got it warehouse in Miami
if you want to pull it pull the whole
stand towards you that's it yes I got a
warehouse in Miami what a freezer and
all the equipment for the seafood you
ought to be able to import and sell
seafood locally and now to stay from
Miami so you were selling seafood
locally and out-of-state yes sir I did
were you a distributor of seafood yes
sir people would bring the seafood to
you would you process it or did you buy
it processed no sir I had a partner she
would accompany Anquetil
let me just if you there you go that's
okay just here it's too close or too far
I had a partnership and accompanying
Nick what all he knows what's bringing
in my food ready processing in 40-foot
containers to Miami let me ask you now
so people can understand what you're
saying just to try to speak slowly and
as clearly as you can so everybody can
follow you because I know it's sometimes
hard with the distortion in the
microphone okay so you had a partnership
in the seafood you said I did how long
did this last for you how many employees
worked for you six and can you give us
an estimate of the volume of business
you were doing 1982 and on the last year
we did about two and a half million
dollars what was the name of this
company Ocean International seafood
ocean international seafood seafood can
you tell us how the business worked my
company I was the president of the
company I was traveling Latin American
to the producing country and buying
seafood from then I'm putting down to
Miami
what were the producer countries
produces countries Brazil Colombia
Venezuela Ecuador Peru Chile come Panama
did you travel to all those countries
yes I do sir
did you buy frozen seafood in those
countries yes I did you ship that
seafood back to Miami yes I do
can you describe the customers that you
serviced the company the customer that
we saw we have Kishin of the ocean man
easy food
Peter Sifu Empire Sifu Pan American Sifu
in New York
Red Lobster okay we're losing you on
this again if you can try just again to
articulate it carefully what were the
names of the companies again Peter
seafood Peter Peter yeah
Peter seafood okay Empire seafood Pan
American seafood in New York
Harry bells in Tampa very luster and so
these are all these are major
distributors yes major companies mm-hmm
and why is the seafood business known
let me strike that where did you also
service hotels and restaurants
no sir no not a Dean just these
distributor company I was only serving
wholesale companies this was a good
business excellent
you did very well in it should be now is
the seafood business in Miami also known
as a business to launder money
yes huh you weren't involved in that
though no I wasn't nothing more than
that but you did know that the seafood
business was known for this yes honey
how did you know that from different
people who told me and different people
who approached me and my travels to
Latin American they will describe that
what kind of approaches were made to you
the approaches was made to me as you
know the seafood business a very high
volume business has to give you a
leaders
nobody's he understand some pound in
stream costs an average I need you to
talk I know you're gonna your instinct
is going to be to talk very fast but I'm
gonna have trouble understanding and I
want to try to do this in English if we
can okay I was approached for the people
in Latin American couple of guys as you
know the seafood base is a very high
volume business just to give an example
the average price of the Polish stream
is around $5 so what you doing you know
to 300,000 pounds a month you got to
come up with a concealer or large amount
of money so there's a great deal of cash
it's always business
yes the reason is a great deal of cash
is because of countries who produce the
stream required to be paying cash so as
a cash operation it becomes an easy
launder target is that right that's
right and you were approached for
laundering purposes yes sir but you
didn't involve you never get involved in
that now how how does cash get concealed
in that seafood operation it's very
simple
what they do is they were cheap you the
merchandise from these countries on
credit basis with the employees saying
and you paying the motion died 30 days
later the mentioned I will come to the
United States right away you can sell
your merchandise for cash or for the
check to any respectable company here
they will pay you right away you got an
invoice saying that you all the money to
that country or to that supply so you
transfer that money to that country to
the bank
you got an invoice already coming from
them so you just paid the account that
money later was brought back to the
United State
declared I mean US customs office in
Miami and it's declared as shrimp money
he was declared like earning money is my
understanding he's not required to
justify any money you are an out of the
country especially for the people coming
out of the country they're not US
citizens they can bring any amount of
cash saying they you know they saw the
owned houses or business and they want
invested money in the United States
did you know of any specific companies
in Miami that used that were involved in
money laundering that were seafood
companies no proof oh I had no proof sir
no proof that's what you heard of
certain yesterday's okay and you knew
which companies you thought were doing
that I guess based on information you
learn talking to people yes sir okay did
you ever hear of
now do you also know whether or not
cocaine was smuggled in frozen shrimp
yes I did how would that be done well
they would they do is that by a company
mm-hmm and the producers company our
countries and they packed the cocaine
inside the frozen food you have to
realize a container of 40-foot container
who have 900 cases shrimp
each case we have three thing take small
boxes from inside so you multiply 900 by
10 you had 9,000 bosses of shrimp
see I'm probably they are the nine
thousand boxes 500 were coming with our
hey kilo of cocaine they would be packed
inside the other bike-riding sign in the
middle on the box and what period do you
know do you know when this kind of
smuggling was going on well you know the
only time that I know it wasn't you was
customs in Miami you know confiscate
achievements when was that
hopefully they got couple of seamen one
for like we're all in 1984 another one
in 1987 46
but you knew prior to 1985 and six you
knew this was going on well you know as
well as poking in those countries you
know how they do it you know they use
anything that could they use flowers
sifu anything that could now before you
came to have some contact with an event
in Haiti
did you help customs with a major
hijacking case yes I did can you
describe that he wasn't hijacking case
in Miami on the seafood there was
stealing's Stream lobster tails and
apparently the FBI and the US Coast was
in Miami I'm it just says that people
were stealing lobster tails yes sir
and shrimp industry due to the volume
the high value on those merchandise I
was approached but he was costume friend
of my personal friend of mine
Hansen they couldn't have anybody who
can help him and ask you to help them
yes you had a reputation as an honest
businessman didn't you I should do you'd
never been arrested never in my life no
no criminal record no I don't wake up no
sir
and then at some point in time did
something take place yes with respect to
Haiti mm-hmm when was that
that was in August 1986 1986 can you
describe to us what happened I was
introduced in Miami by one of my family
member by the this woman whose name was
Morel dill annoying who is me railed
Illinois me right doll annoying that
time identify himself like the wife of
the very high-ranking military guy in
Haiti and what is the name of that
high-ranking military guy Joan Krupa
jean-claude Paul yes sir
was she at that time married to him or
divorced in that time she claimed she
told me that she was married to him and
you had occasion to have a meeting with
her yes I did what was the purpose of
that meeting the meeting original was
that she want to invest some kind of
money that you have has some kind of
reason in Miami and saying she came
through this family member you know she
told me she could invest in some kind of
seafood since you know it was a high and
a good reason to get into she also tell
me that you know in Haiti a couple of
factories who produce shrimp fish and
lobster tails now she probably can be
both these people to bring back the
United States how did you respond to her
offer
how was very interesting why are you
interested well because as you know this
is a very high demand seafood in this
country just to give you an idea you
know this country consumed four million
pounds stream today so you know what's
very interesting it meant good business
to you excellent so did she invite you
to visit Haiti
she did and that invitation was issued
in 1986 he was in 1986 at what month
these happen around the middle of
September
you accepted her offer to go to Haiti
yes I did and in fact did you go to
Haiti yes I did when did you go to Haiti
I went in the head is Ryan dnl all
September 1986 who accompanied you on
that truck he was a friend of mine named
Tony Mirra Illinois I her son did you
fly a commercial identity yes I did okay
did you know at that time who Colonel
jean-claude Paul was no sort of not at
all so would you describe for us what
took place when you arrived in Haiti yes
the suit we are robbing Haiti Miguel
went right in the front
Slone our Beach yes mr. Illinois just
went in the front and he was two
soldiers waiting for her right and in
the stay up at the airplane they helped
with the capital back that she has and
also her son was following her he
started running to the group of people
was sitting in the airport right about
half a block away from the plane me and
my friend was walking right follow her
to that group of people that group of
people was about 12 people all dressed
in military clothes so they soon were
getting close to this group of people we
was called by the soldiers behind mrs.
Illinois to stay a little bit behind how
she went close to these parts on this
guy who you know she started talking to
him he say he giving the keys to his son
and they start talking in Creole took up
a couple of minutes you know this person
approaches he was introduced to us by
Morell Dillon oi husband John crop oh so
that's when you first met John
that has the airport yes now during this
visit were you offered a chance to
purchase seafood yes sir
and were you offered that seafood below
the market price yes
do you know why you were offered it
below the market price not really sir we
went to the to the place and he told us
that he can get all the seafood he could
well describe for me how this offer came
about you were in the company of Jean
Claude Paul yes okay well what did you
what did what did you learn about
general applaud Paul as you traveled
with him well if the first thing we
learned was there soon was going to go
through the immigration line in Haiti I
didn't understand it there at all
yeah the first thing we learn about him
he was the first thing we did from Ghana
Haiti was trying to go to the
immigration line to help a support you
know stems young crop took away your
passport and gone you know went around
call a guy who was in the Immigration
Department kick him the path of war and
the first of all was stand right there
no question as from there we went right
to the costume department and all the
costume this walking salute
John Clapham my handbag right up in the
table to be open to be check how they
soon they swung he saw me with
jean-claude Paul he was not necessary I
went right through custom window check
it out from there he was a full military
aside by it was driving to to your lion
cruisers agree mercedes-benz two
motorcycles with plain clothes gars and
he was another issues right behind we
was drivin Antonio Paul his brother from
there we stole I was sitting in the back
with party that I went to Haiti with
and to military soldiers driving in the
front
yong-ho poll on morale was sitting the
frong in the mercedes-benz as far as you
were concerned you were there to try to
arrange for shrimp deal yes sir were you
surprised at this point to be in the
company of Colonel jean-claude Paul well
the the first I was very surprised and
even we thought for a minute that he was
not a colonel he was a general and in
fact we used to call him you know
because we didn't know what gray or the
military had but by the way he you know
his uniform was we thought it was a
general were there any other and what
other indications can you share with us
about Colonel Jean Claude's Paul's power
well in that time we didn't realize you
know how probably really was we was
drove to the hotel in port-au-prince
called El Rancho this hotel is one of
the most loosely hotel and
port-au-prince this room we walk into
the hotel he was couple of guys dressed
in plain clothes
we often to rate the hotel they did
everything for us they give us the best
room and was treating like a VIP all
away at some point when this deal to buy
shrimp below market price were the
companies that you talk to were they
able to turn down the below market price
offer were they able to get full price
if they wanted to
yes sir we went to the company in
port-au-prince we don't go up or on his
wife and again within a couple of
soldiers consumed we're walking in their
company there's not a cloud Paul is with
you yes sir you go to the company he was
right with us what happened
he was running to the seafood company he
was the the company was my two brothers
Fiat recorded right they name was Simon
we sit around and mr. Simon showed us
the different kind of seafood that his
guy and we saw right in the corner he
had a bunch of boxes already back to be
cheap to United State for last details
apparently has some commitment with some
company knew you're ready I didn't
understand him sighs apparently he has
some commitment he has a commitment for
the merchandising he having a stock in
that time and he told me we don't mind
to show you the merchandise probably got
some commitment and I have to achieve
these people the merchandise otherwise
you know they'll lend me some money
ahead and I could not pay you so I was
taught I told me read Illinois and say
well you know could be the next time
would be no problem so when she told you
uncle Paul he said no no you shouldn't
win now
you know I mean it was very emphasis
there you know the chimney had to be
sold to me because I was buying cash for
the shipment and also you know I was a
phrase so shoot a good achievement
nobody else but out did Colonel Paul
expect anything for helping you to make
this right connection yes so he did or
what did he expect he never told me the
rep or everything all the conversation
went to his wife he wants to get pay a
dollar a pound for his panel of seafood
we buying Haiti and that's what his wife
told you at that time sir and it was
there any discussion of drugs on his
first trip not at all from there we went
to couple all the seafood places he took
us and he invited us to go to his range
he's about 90 minutes away from
port-au-prince we had we would walk to
the range the range was well guarded
but the military this is his ranch yes
we went right inside and we sold a bunch
of militaries around you know what
uniform and we plainclothes - did you
get to see anything else about the
lifestyle and Jean Claude Paul yes we
did the way that he live he was very
well compared with their will people the
way people live in Haiti would it be
very well compared with the salary of a
colonel
well I don't have an idea how much the
current amazing Haiti but I can tell you
you know to assume some of the knowledge
that I have somebody tell in Latin
American maze John Paul was above that
level what things did you observe he had
a tumor cells veins - brand-new to your
aslan Cruces a brand new wooden waffle
Motorhome very rarely you see one of
those in Haiti when a bagel yes sir
Thanks
he had the house in the ranch he was
well furniture here conditions stereos
called TV and what else big antenna he
can catch all these stations from the
United State satellite dish
yes was there also an airstrip here we
didn't notice in that time he was Ito
goes around the ranch in his truck and
we went by the edge three about two
times but in that time they were Elstree
was well-covered
they had cows and piles of grass in the
airstrip at a later time you came to see
the airstrip yes I get it we'll come
back to that well why are the soldiers
of the dessaline s barracks so important
in Haiti this arena is right behind the
presidential palace
he's my understand they lead on the
Hessian army and they very lawyer the
only answer to conk la Pole did they
play any role do you know in the
elections of last November it's my
understanding to the information that I
have and the information for the price
they the one who really took over I mean
they really not took over personally in
the attack but there was they let it
happen to the tonton Macoutes
did you come to learn he is also the
head of the tan-tan Lecoq I understand
is the military Magneton to mcgoon
did you see any evidence of that via the
respect that may have how did you come
into contact with any of the members of
the tonton Macoutes well you know I
probably did but I would didn't know
because they oh well you know playing
clothes and they all wear guns so you
don't know if they military we put on
clothes or Tonto makuu's I think mr.
chairman it said it's worthy of note
that not only does he command those
barracks but if he's not the head he
certainly is in the hierarchy of the
tonton Macoutes
and as as it relates to Haiti and drug
trafficking and human rights violations
and terrorism we have one individual
tied up in one package who represents a
little worst of all of those elements
mr. chairman now let me suggest to some
of my colleagues and friends who wonder
why and interest in in Haiti we see
direct direct tyranny to the people in
in light of the tens and tens of
thousands who in order to escape that
tyranny we so often find washing ashore
some who never make it a lie some will
do anything to escape what is taking
place and so we have a a an incredible
situation developing and we have done
little of anything really in terms of
utilizing our moral legal responsibility
and the power that we have to correct
that situation it has been half-hearted
and of course I've already got myself
embroiled in somewhat of a controversy
as it relates to my characterization not
of the individuals but of their lack of
activity and action and I say we would
be less than I would be less than candid
if I didn't say that we certainly lack
any courageous action in our dealing and
they can take in any
they want and I want to be said for the
wreck you lack of any kind of courageous
actions in dealing with the outrages
that have been heaped upon the people of
Haiti particularly in in this past year
it is absolutely incredible it is a blow
to to this nation to what we're supposed
to stand for for the leaders of the free
world for democracy for what's right
what's proper to allow the barbaric rule
to continue and to suppress the people
of Haiti is something that this senator
has a difficult time understanding and I
imagine there's a school of thought
although I have not heard it explained
to me yet that would say well if we if
these people fall there's somebody who's
apt to be even worse well I I don't know
how you could make it worse when we've
seen hundreds of thousands of people
flee for their lives risk their lives
and and and we just continue that doing
business as if nothing's changed so I
just wanted to put that lever
announcement in the record yes let me
i'ma stand I'm out of going back to the
tone to McCool you probably know the
Haitian army he's been compound for
about 7,000 men's the Tonto MacEwan
Haiti they rose up to 40,000 means or it
hasn't men yes in the Tonto comic
anatomical alone so if you get these
together that John Paul has the elite of
the Haitian troops on his command loyal
to him to him Plus also has 40,000 means
he's this possible
anytime that he wants I don't believe
the people here he has too much chance
Oh unless you the people who had the
power would do something about it really
I want to we'll come back to that and
a question of the thing let me just
comment also Senator Graham of Florida
has an interest in this area he does not
serve on the subcommittee but he is a
member of the drug caucus and he asked
that we hold some of this testimony till
he is able to join us and I've agreed to
do that so we will have further
testimony with respect to Haiti at a
subsequent time when we are back in
session but let me come back now I want
to go through John Claude and Paul and
lead into the involvement with narcotics
which is obviously central here you then
returned to ma how long did you stay on
this first trip in Haiti Haiti we are
right on Friday and I love them Sunday
it's fair to say though you knew people
in Miami who were members of the Haitian
community there yes I did you were
familiar with Haiti yes I did
now you returned to Miami did you return
with mrs. Delano who was the wife of
Jean Claude Paul no she's staying Haiti
to the following Monday okay at some
time after you returned to Miami did she
contact you yes you did and when was
that that wasn't Tuesday that shortly
afterwards I after day after she arrived
and at that time did she want you to
help her dispose of some cocaine and
that time she called me and told me that
she want to talk to me he not told him
that I will go to her house after I
finished work on my on my way house do
you have any idea or what she was going
to talk about no no not at all so you
went to her house yes I did and you had
a conversation with her yes I did was
anybody else present in that time it was
me her and she had a bodyguard in the
house all the time
and he was the only person present at
that time
how did she bring this up how did this
come up well geez the first thing she
mention was that she had a problem then
they want to achieve on invest some
money in the seafood but the main
problem she has to get
out of Haiti and she told me that on
Monday she keeps the money to a lady
friend of her to go to cabo hi Gianna
which is the part of her for the tourist
boat arrived and he was he's a big
traveling dollars there so when she
keyed the money to this lady apparently
she did not bought the dollars she trot
the local currency for cocaine I'm sorry
excuse me
she asked you to turn the dollar let me
ask you for that answer again and I
apologize okay she told me that you know
she keep the money to a lady in front of
her to go to cava height right you know
to buy the dollar from the tourist boat
had she went there the lady didn't
bought not dollars which he bought it
was four hundred and twelve kilo who
came and she told me that she had a
problem because she don't know what to
do with the merchandise saying she never
was involved in this kind of deals what
did she request you to do she told me
first if I want to do it I told him that
I never was involving that kind of that
kind of drug deals but she told me then
if I know anybody who you know who know
somebody who was able to do this tranche
in my back to Miami in that time I
thought I probably do but I got a can to
this person
let me slow you down here you said to
her that you probably knew somebody who
could do that yes I did and then what
did you say then I told him that I will
get encounter probably with this person
and then the next day she says is why I
should not call him right there like you
know in five minutes so
citizen this guy he was a good friend of
mine I call him he called me back an
hour later all this time I was waiting
at her house and her talking to come
down to the missus Illinois
to discuss this matter did she offer you
money she offered me $100,000 Commission
for this job
and did you did you know that the person
that you were calling was involved in
narcotics he was not involved in my
career that I know of but I had a lot of
people that he knows who was did that
person then come down to the house yes
he did
what happened well he had a meeting with
her and he has heard a lot of questions
first question was you know safety
quality of the merchandise and quantity
sukoon and all these questions so she
went right to the phone and Corrigan was
her husband in Haiti were you present
during that conversation yes I was
what did she say to him I could not tell
you that senator because he was in
Creole okay but let me rephrase assume
the conversation went very positive
because right after she hung up she told
me them house they want me and my
opponent to go by to Haiti on Friday and
who was to go back to Haiti me and the
guy that I called at the time that she
called her husband Colonel jean-claude
Paul had you agreed to help her did you
agree the deal was on you were gonna
take $800,000 no sir no I did not
agreeing anything
what was she calling him about she
called him apparently to see because
since this friend of mine was asked her
a couple of question about where the
merchant I was what kind of quality she
couldn't answer the details I say so she
called him to get approve to going back
with us to talk to him the rep what
happened how did this meeting conclude
concluded that we was going to go to
Haiti they following Friday
this is Tuesday this is Tuesday and the
next Friday you were gonna go to here's
me okay by the way let me rephrase there
Chi as opposed to going to her Wednesday
that's day [ __ ] I did I had nobody to
open my business I thought that I
couldn't go to Friday did the Haitians
come back to you and insist that you
participate in this transaction
she caught me a couple of times in my
seafood place and to make sure that I
was gonna go so did you agree to go to
Haiti yes did you have to take special
steps to have your business taken care
of while you were gone
yes I did you left for Haiti on Friday I
left for head in front of us did you fly
back with Miss Estella Noi yeah Friday
with her my partner I mean what is the
date of this trip or month at least
certainty was the first day of October
he had to be there third of the second
of October
you know to the 1986 October 1986 okay
and you went to port-au-prince yes we
went to port-au-prince hey were you met
in the same way at the airport this time
you know when the Sioux mover got out of
the plane deep he was riding in the
field waiting for us what the field him
the international pole a jeep was right
at the field right next to the airplane
sent you mr. John crop or he wasn't
there so that Jeep we got on the G and
they drove us all the way up to the
terminal and did you proceed to go to
Colonel Paul's ranch no sir he worked
when I was right there and he started
into morale he started to what talking
to his wife and he he told us about it
to get to him the passaport to go
through immigration and
again so he did this thing operationally
the first time and what rice I he put us
in a car with two soldiers to be dropped
down to the hotel game while she well i
him was going to talk to something about
the situation the reason we're going to
hate in this time because this part of
my requests to see how this mercy and I
was packet I think how this merchandise
quality was your partner wanted to see
the packaging and quality and at this
time you were going along with this
deals at Chris I went with him
and when were you taken to his ranch how
was we first stay in the hotel that day
almost one about four hours alone mirell
show up around 10:30 10:30 and 9:00 what
another girl they seemed to lose to us
that her sister yeah they she told Asif
is you were gonna take we're gonna take
a ride with her in their car you want to
take a sip of water and relax for a
minute let me let me just say for the
record here that mr. Quint Anna is
appearing under a considerable amount of
pressure that's been placed on him by
the circumstances of his current
situation mr. Quinn Tony your life has
been threatened is that accurate yes sir
and in fact is it true this committee
has been informed that a price has been
put on your head is that accurate yes
sir
do you know how much that is soon a
thousand dollars and in fact has there
been an attempt on your life twice twice
and that took place in Miami is that not
yes sir and that has been documented by
the DEA is that accurate yeah the first
thing was to write in the DEA building
in Miami and I was with the yeah you
know that time and is it accurate that
you
at one point in the last week's had
taken to carrying a machine gun yourself
I always do you always carry a machine
gun since this problem just didn't
you're not carrying one now good let me
ask you something can you identify the
group that Colonel Poole hired they put
the contract out on your life we
understand that the country came through
the first contract came through some
cages in Miami some all bodies of his
from the term to McCune these people was
arrested in Miami by DEA the second
contract since then one to be sure of
like it was a Haitian contract they hire
a Columbia family in New York who
represent the interest or the Escobar
family in Medellin he understand that
family's name is the cult their own
family their own family operating out of
New York City
yes sir and that's my understanding and
the same time they called their own
family hiya hello Camela in Miami which
is an obligation named Lionel willing as
chairman I think that as you and I well
know that linkage between again the
Colombians and these other drug dealers
once again comes back and here's a hit
team that is recruited that is part of
the Calderon family probably one of the
most vicious and then responsible for
some of the most brutal murders in the
New York area including men women
children infants who have been gunned
down and are known for their for their
ruthlessness well I appreciate your
going into that part of the questioning
because it's I think it underscores the
nature of what one is dealing with here
every time you turn around one country
another there's a Colombian tentacle
Medellin Cartel tentacle or at least a
connection is that accurate okay
and with respect to your life now it's
fair to say that your business has been
totally disrupted is it not yes sir and
you are currently under protection
obviously yes sir okay I'd like to come
back now to the sequence as we proceed
here but as your voice was breaking I
just wanted people to understand the
pressure and stress that you've been
under these recent days and we will go
into a couple of those attempts on your
life at a later time you went back to
the ranch with Colonel Paul correct no
let's stay right in the hotel a moment
sir okay
she came down with her sister only since
go Sloane and she she came down with
another girl who she dint define her
like a her sister
this is mrs. Delano yes all right she
told us if we can take a ride with her
in the car that she not waiting outside
so we got inside the car as soon we
drove out of the hotel
she supply I don't her handbag a kilo of
cocaine seal and his sample of about
five six ounces in a bottle okay Maura
she told my friend this that's how the
drug was packing and that was the sample
for the quality and she will discuss the
detail the next day with us he realized
the quality and the merchandise then
what happened we went back to the room
with the sample and this friend of my
you know to some deaths in the room
through some aluminum papers and matches
can realize that drug was a very high
quality drug in that time he assumed he
was between 89 and 92 percent pure so we
went to bed and the next morning around
7 o'clock
mrs. Illinois should hop again with the
hotel this time alone to have breath
over us while she was talking to my
friend I would out sigh
to bite one of those cakes on painting
you know frames was I was talking to the
guy outside to buy one of those she came
in out with this friend of mine and I
told him that I was gonna get some money
to buy the painting for the guy she
called one of the soldier was there she
tell me what's the one you like so point
to her
what friend that I like they went right
there three pop the freak out of this
guy huh
booze problem I'll give it to me come
didn't pay the guy I went but to the guy
and I was gonna try to pay him you know
he said nah don't worry about it you
know the guy was very afraid to do
anything so we got back in the truck and
she told us she was going to drive Oh me
and my friend to the dessaline barracks
right behind the presidential palace
when her hospice was waiting for us so
we were driving down I saw one of those
portals Oh shells for the shell so you
know I fell in love with it what do you
what so the one who was there she
stopped the car and called the guy who
was selling the total hey McKay came
over and we start discussing the prices
and the guy didn't agree with the prices
start walking back one of the soldiers
behind us got off the truck rip off the
Toro this guy Han we take off again
ripped off what the shell took the shell
yes and threw it in the back of the
truck no and just drove away all the way
that's what we went to the decent
barracks he went under Salinas barracks
yes he's right behind the presidential
palace in port-au-prince
so we were right inside and John Paul II
was waiting for us in his office we sit
down and she stopped talking to her him
in Creole in the meanwhile all these
questions in the car was asked to the
annoying kebab landing field securities
nations how do you know he can land a
plane down there here your
friend was asking these questions yes
about how to land a plane what were the
security precautions in other words your
friend was laying the groundwork yes for
your pickup of the narcotics
it's like Lisa okay and was she
answering these questions miss Estella
nah she do not know that all the answers
so that's why you went to see Colonel
Paul well you know we had a meeting with
him anyway but she told us to wait we
can get to the get those answers from
him and did you in fact have a
conversation with Colonel Paul yes we
did regarding the plans for how to pick
up the narcotics yes sir
and did he tell you about the security
he you know he want us to take it right
with him to the range to show you where
you could pick it up he told me you know
let's take it right to the range so did
you drive to the ranch yes we did with
Colonel Paul Kohner Polk was driving
person on this time his wife was seated
right next to him me and my friend was
sitting behind and to motorcycle were
playing clothes was driving right beside
us what kind of car is this he was at
the 1985-86 Toyota Landcruiser
and you drove to the ranch in this car
yes it's a brown one what did you see
when you got to the ranch again it
wasn't totally security again and we
went right to the house has we seen in
the house we start talking about it he
the first question he answers he would
like the merchandise the answer was from
the front of my yes the second question
he asks he will get them the way to pick
him up and the friend of mine say well
you gotta go back to Miami and depend
what are you gonna tell us what can I do
we can make he can made the arrangement
for he asks us he what do we use playing
a boat the friend of mine you know told
him either one
and then we had a map he come out with a
map
I don't know if it was a navigation lab
or a flower map he let down the map on
the floor and pointed man with the ranch
was the first question my friends I said
well I know where the ranch is what's
get to do with I said well because I
gotta show you the landing strip that I
have so he took you out to show you a
landing personal to goes to see the
landing field what did you see there
well he was the same place that ivory I
told you that before the the last three
who was was a bunch of cows I grass
we're gonna we'll take a break in a
minute so you can rest but let me just
finish this piece of it where the cows
and the grass was previously there was
this big strip yeah it was true now with
nothing on he was totally plain were
their landing lights in that time he
showed us the connection in the floor he
showed you what Scott the couple of
cables lay down on the floor you know or
connecting the landing lights yes okay
and how was the runway strike that how
long was the runway well you know that
was the first question we asked him how
long was the runway so mr. Poe got
yourself inside a pickup truck I mean
these Toyota Landcruiser
police odometer is zero and dropped to
one into another and the landing field
was one point six miles 1.6 miles long
yes so could handle pretty big airplanes
yeah
jets all kinds also he we asked about
refueling
he showed us right in the end the field
couple of various tanks drums with pumps
that they used to refuel the plane in
that time he told us to we gotta tell
him what kind of plane was using because
they paint what kind of plane was using
that's the kind of gasoline that we need
so he's got to be totally innovators now
was a deal struck for the delivery of
the cocaine in that time no what
happened was we asked him do you think
we can take some pictures of the field
and this around is around and this
friend of mine start taking pictures one
of the pictures with DEA has Colonel
Paul inside the trot driving around the
field but also the feel the amount is
and everything else in the field how
much cocaine was involved at this time
in the discussion he was talking about
four hundred and twelve kilos in that
time how much money was your plot Paul
to be paid he thought of you $1000 but
the first time how much the first time
he told us he won $10,000 for kilo per
kilo yes four hundred and twelve kilos
yes was anyone else supposed to receive
a cut in that time we didn't know
anybody else they don't we fund down it
was somebody else years later on your
father and who did you find out who else
was to get a cut
he was Antonio I'm to all the partners
that he got he never told us what it was
when did you learn that when I'm Tonio
Paul
float back to Miami very scared because
somebody told him that we was taking
pictures of the field in this trip well
we're gonna take about ten minute recess
at this point so you can try to hang on
to your voice here and then we'll pick
up with your testimony we stand in
recess for ten minutes